I was born with a chance to be
somebody I'm going to be the most famous
man in the whole
[Music]
[Applause]
world Mr President the Confederacy is
dead the union is saved the war is
[Music]
over
freedom for the
sou what happened president's been shot
Witnesses are saying it were John wilt's
boo wait the
actor do you know who I am I'm a
symbol how does a well-known actor
commit murder in front of an audience of
1500 people and
Escape find the man that killed my
husband
been gentlemen I am tasking you with the
capture John wils Booth all of
[Music]
thisen this is a conspiracy to dismember
our government I know who you are Mr
Booth you're going to help us or not
there's a bounty on the head of Booth I
intend to
collect Booth is being protected by the
Confederacy now with Lincoln out of the
way this country belongs to
us I will not surrender may God be my
Jud God Bless
[Applause]
America